heute vor elf jahren wurde der meist
gejagt für mann der welt getötet osama
bin laden der drahtzieher von nine
eleven der terroranschläge 2001 in den
usa
unvergessen das bild von us präsident
obama und außenministerin hillary
clinton die live zugeschaltet waren als
eine spezialeinheit in das schlafzimmer
von bin laden eindrang und durchaus
erschrocken zu sein wie er getötet wurde
was genau dort passierte erzählt uns
heute abend um 20 uhr 15 der mann der
abdrückte der held der bin laden tötete
so der titel der großen doku babbels
unser reporter maximilian kiewel konnte
mit ihm sprechen
roger neill schaut dem bösen ins gesicht
er zögert keine sekunde und drückt
dreimal ab vor genau elf jahren am
zweiten mai 2011 erschoss der
elitesoldat den drahtzieher der
anschläge vom 11 september
massenmörder osama bin laden im
pakistanischen abottabad stürmt o'neal
mit seiner einheit das terror versteck
und schaltet den terrorfürsten mit drei
kopfschüssen aus im explosiven bild live
interview erinnert sich der soldat an
die mission seines lebens sie laufen die
treppe hoch schieben einen vorhang zur
seite plötzlich ist da eine gruppe
menschen mein kamerad denkt dass sie
selbstmordattentäter sind er springt
sofort auf sie um mich zu schützen und
sein leben zu opfern und zum glück waren
diese frauen aber unbewaffnet ich drehe
mich also in die andere richtung und da
steht obama bin laden seine hände liegen
auf den schultern seiner frau
gibt sich nicht gibt mir keine chance
ihn festzunehmen er ist eine gefahr er
bewegt sich halte ihn für einen
selbstmordattentäter und muss ihn
genauso behandeln deshalb habe ich in
der schossen es gleicht einem wunder
aber o'neill und seine kameraden
überleben den gefährlichen einsatz
unverletzt denn eigentlich waren sich
die seals sicher wir werden auf dieser
mission sterben und zogen sie trotzdem
durch
ich habe an meine eltern meine frau und
meine kinder ein abschiedsbrief
geschrieben einen brief an jeden eine
meiner töchter wir haben gerade noch
telefoniert war damals sieben jahre alt
als sie ihr diesen abschiedsbrief
geschrieben habe da habe ich nicht an
die siebenjährige geschrieben sondern
ich habe mir vorgestellt dass die 27
ich habe ihr geschrieben es tut mir
unendlich leid dass ich deine hochzeit
von brüssel ich bin mir sicher dass du
wunderschön bist danke dass du auf deine
mama aufpasst und auf deine geschwister
ich habe versucht er zu erklären warum
das richtig war diese missionen
durchzuführen
natürlich habe ich dabei geweint aber
sie musste einfach wissen warum ich in
diesen einsatz gegangen wenn sie
verdiente eine antwort
mir ist der letzte mensch den osama bin
laden in seinem mörderischen lebensjahr
das ganze interview mit dem helden
soldaten heute abend um 20.15 exklusiv
bei bild tv
eine packende und auch ergreifende
dokumentation die ich ihnen sehr ans
herz legen kann meine damen und herren
also wie gesagt heute abend ab 20.15
hierbei bild